[Music]
that's ben diesel stepping in to walk
meadow walker down the aisle as she got
married over the weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
and yep we are in our feelings it's
probably the biggest blessing the 22
year old model and daughter of late
actor paul walker who died in 2013 took
to instagram to reveal that she tied the
knot with louis thornton allen posting
this sweet black and white video of
their dominican wedding captioning it
we're married
[Music]
and who better to step in for dad than
his best friend people go you know
what's it like making a movie without
pablo
and that's not the right question what's
it like living without
your brother you know what i mean it's
not about making a movie it's about if
i'm on a set of another movie if i ever
had a concern or something i would call
him
and i don't have that call now and i
don't have that person that's dreaming
up the impossible with me the bride
stunned in a timeless white wedding gown
with a long veil by givenchy while the
fast and the furious actor looked
handsome in a gray suit
vin's co-star jordana brewster was also
in attendance and was seen hugging
meadow
[Music]
meadow and louie announced their
engagement in august the model showed
off her diamond ring in a video posted
on her instagram
meadow has remained close to her
father's famous friends
your daughter must think you're like the
coolest dad in the whole wide world she
thinks i'm a dork
she does jordana previously predicted to
e.t that she could make an appearance in
the fast and the furious movie franchise
before it wraps up could we see her in
any of the finals oh for sure absolutely
she'll be in one of the movies you think
i think so i would love that